Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Come, cheer up, my lads. Tis to glory we steer,
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻轻点按几次即可在应用内订阅。来吧，伙计们，振作起来，我们要驶向荣耀，
to add something more to this wonderful year. To honour we call you, as free men, not slaves. For who are so free as the sons of the waves? Heart of ochre are ships, jolly tars are our men. We always are ready, steadyady, boys, steady. We'll fight and we'll conquer again and again. We ne'er see our foes, but we wish them to stay. They never see us, but they wish us away.
为这个精彩的年份再添一笔。我们召唤你们作为自由人而不是奴隶去赢得荣誉。因为谁能比海的儿女更自由？赤土之心的战舰，快乐的水手是我们的船员。我们随时准备着，稳住，伙计们，稳住。我们将一次又一次地战斗并取得胜利。我们从未见过敌人，但我们希望他们留下。他们从未见过我们，但他们希望我们离去。
If they run, why, we follow and run them ashore. For if they won't fight us, what can we do more? So Tom Holland, that's Heart of Oak, written in 1759 after the Battle of Quiberon Bay and sung a few hours aboard the Victory before the Great Battle of Trafalgar in 1805. So one of the great anthems of the Royal Navy. And you have wanted to do a podcast about Trafalgar since we started The Rest is History, haven't you? I have. And this is the perfect week to be doing it because Friday, the 21st of October, is Trafalgar Day,
如果他们逃跑，好吧，我们追赶并把他们逼上岸。因为如果他们不与我们战斗，我们还能做什么？那么，汤姆·霍兰，那是《橡木之心》，写于1759年基伯龙湾海战之后，并在1805年特拉法尔加大战前的几个小时内在“胜利号”上唱响。因此，这是皇家海军的伟大颂歌之一。自从我们创办《历史余音》以来，你一直想做一期关于特拉法尔加的播客，对吧？我是想过。而这正是做这期节目的绝佳星期，因为10月21日星期五就是特拉法尔加日，
the day on which the battle was actually fought. So we were originally going to do one episode, weren't we? We were. On Trafalgar. And I went away on holiday and I started reading about it and I read about it
也就是这场战役实际打响的日子。所以我们原本打算做一期节目，对吧？是的。关于特拉法尔加。然后我休假去了，我开始阅读关于它的资料，我读了又读，
and I read about it and I read about it and I sent you a text saying, I think we should do two episodes. Well, we're now going to be doing three episodes so we're going to talk about today a world at war the the background to this great battle Napoleon against Nelson France against Britain the elephant against the whale this great clash next time we will look at the build-up to the battle and then on friday the 21st of october trafalgar day we will look at the actual battle itself and
我读了又读，我读了又读，我给你发了一条短信，说，我觉得我们应该做两期节目。好吧，我们现在要做三期节目，所以我们要谈论今天的话题：一个处于战争中的世界、这场伟大战役的背景、拿破仑对阵纳尔逊、法国对阵英国、大象对阵鲸鱼、这场伟大的冲突；下一次我们将探讨战役的筹备阶段；然后在10月21日星期五，特拉法尔加日，我们将审视战役本身以及
um dominic i have gone on record haven't i as saying that i'm not particularly interested in rope or ships or mizzen masks or anything like that right because this is in the context of the novels of patrick o'brien that refused to read. I now want to recant. I want to recant. Oh, what a moment. I think this is an absolutely thrilling story. I think it's the great epic of British history, actually. And when I say epic, I mean in the sense that, the Homeric sense. Nelson is a kind of a disinfigure, endlessly sweeping the seas.
嗯，多米尼克，我有过公开记录，对吧，说过我对绳索、船只、中桅或类似的东西不是特别感兴趣？对，因为这是在拒绝阅读的帕特里克·奥布莱恩的小说的背景下说的。我现在想收回这话。我想收回。哦，真是个历史性时刻。我觉得这是一个极其惊心动魄的故事。实际上，我认为这是英国历史上的伟大史诗。当我说是史诗时，我是指在这个意义上，荷马史诗的意义。纳尔逊是一种狂怒的化身，无休止地横扫海洋。
He's on the sea at two years at a time. And then at Trafalgar, the Byron called him Britannia's god of war. He's a kind of great agent of annihilation, a kind of terrifying figure really, who dies at the moment of his triumph, becomes the great martyr of the Navy. Well, that obviously, we'll come to that. But that martyrdom is absolutely central to the story. It's an astonishing story. And it's a story in which the stakes could not be higher. For Britain, it's about national survival. And for France, it's about the opportunity to knock Britain out permanently, and thereby secure a permanent French supremacy
他在海上一次就能待上两年。然后在特拉法尔加，拜伦称他为“不列颠的战神”。他实际上是某种伟大的毁灭力量，一个真正可怕的人物，他在胜利的那一刻死去，成为了海军伟大的烈士。好吧，很显然，我们会谈到这一点。但这种殉道对这个故事至关重要。这是一个令人震惊的故事。在这个故事中，赌注高得不能再高。对英国而言，这是关乎国家生存的问题；而对法国而言，这是彻底击垮英国、并借此确保法国对欧洲永久统治地位的契机。
over Europe. So huge, huge stakes. But there is a debate about Trafalgar, and how decisive it actually is. So there are historians who say it didn't really change anything particularly. What's your view on that? Because I actually think that it's probably the most decisive battle of the 19th century for reasons that we'll come to in due course. Yeah, I probably agree with you, Tom. I think there are some battles that do feel like decisive showdowns or turning points. So, I mean, naval battles, you know, the Battle of Actium maybe, or the Battle of Midway or something. And I think Trafalgar is obviously in the very top rank of those. Because I think what it does, I mean, we'll come on to talk about the geopolitical ramifications later. But I think what Trafalgar does is it ultimately,
所以赌注极其巨大。但关于特拉法尔加以及它到底有多决定性，一直存在争论。因此，有些历史学家说它其实并没有真正改变什么。你对此有什么看法？因为我实际上认为，由于我们稍后会谈到的原因，它可能是19世纪最具决定性的战役。是的，我可能同意你的看法，汤姆。我认为有些战役确实感觉像是决定性的对决或转折点。我的意思是，海战，你知道，或许是亚克兴海战，或者是中途岛战役之类的。我认为特拉法尔加显然属于其中最高级别。因为我认为它的作用，我的意思是，我们稍后会谈到地缘政治的影响。但我认为特拉法尔加的作用最终是，
you could argue, it makes it impossible for the French to win, to knock Britain out of the Napoleonic Wars. Had Trafalgar gone otherwise, had the French landed in Britain, and maybe not invaded, but maybe smashed up Britain's dockyards, smashed up London and so on, made it impossible for Britain to continue to fight at sea. That would have had enormous ramifications for the war in Europe, but also in the long term, over the course of the 19th century, for the imperial balance of power. And I would say Trafalgar ensures that Britain will be the world's largest commercial and imperial power for the next hundred years or so. Absolutely. And I think there's a paradox
你可以说，它让法国人无法获胜，无法将英国踢出拿破仑战争。如果特拉法尔加的结果不同，如果法国人在英国登陆，也许没有入侵，但也许砸毁了英国的造船厂，砸毁了伦敦等等，使得英国无法继续在海上作战。那将对欧洲的战争产生巨大影响，从长远来看，也会对19世纪的帝国权力平衡产生巨大影响。我要说的是，特拉法尔加确保了英国在未来一百年左右成为世界上最大的商业和帝国强国。绝对是这样。而且我认为这里面存在一个悖论，
there, which is that perhaps it's less decisive as a battle in the Napoleonic Wars than it is as a battle in the broad context of the 19th century, which is kind of a seeming paradox that perhaps we can look at when we actually come to the battle itself but just to um just to jump in though tom i agree with you about the homeric epic and i think the the fact that the the figure at the center of the of the struggle i mean it's that strange thing isn't it where one there are two figures who everybody knows nelson and napoleon napoleon is never there but he hangs his shadow hangs over the whole story but nelson is there in a very intimate kind of way on the deck of the victory risking his life and of course it a very intimate kind of way on the deck of the victory, risking his life. And of course, it's the fact that he dies in the moment of apotheosis
那就是，作为拿破仑战争中的一场战役，它可能不如它在19世纪宏大背景下的战役那么具有决定性，这似乎是一个悖论，也许当我们真正谈到这场战役本身时可以探讨一下。不过，汤姆，我得插一句，我同意你关于荷马史诗的看法，而且我认为，这场斗争中心的人物——我的意思是，那是一种奇怪的事情，不是吗？有两个世人皆知的人物：纳尔逊和拿破仑。拿破仑从不在现场，但他的阴影笼罩着整个故事；而纳尔逊却以一种非常亲密的方式出现在“胜利号”的甲板上，冒着生命危险。当然，正是他在神圣化达到顶点的那一刻死去，
that turns this into more than just an ordinary battle. It turns it into an absolute, I hate to use the word because it's such a terrible cliche, but it turns it into, dare I say, an iconic moment in British national history. But there's one other thing I think makes Trafalgar so interesting. And I know at this point, you'll roll your eyes because you're terrified that I'm going to start talking about 17th century finance. But I think Trafalgar is the culmination of all kinds of political, financial, economic, cultural processes that have been working themselves out for more than 100 years. And it's a brilliant window, actually, into talking about Britain as a state since its creation. Absolutely. Well, so Andrew Lambert, great naval historian, biographer of Nelson,
才使这场战役超越了一场普通的战斗。它把它变成了一个绝对的——我讨厌用这个词，因为它是如此糟糕的陈词滥调——但它把它变成了一个，我敢说，英国国家历史上的标志性时刻。但还有一件事我认为让特拉法尔加如此有趣。我知道此时你会翻白眼，因为你害怕我会开始谈论17世纪的金融。但我认为特拉法尔加是一百多年来一直在酝酿的各种政治、财政、经济、文化进程的顶峰。实际上，它为了解英国自建国以来的国家形态提供了一个极好的窗口。绝对是这样。好吧，安德烈·兰伯特，伟大的海军历史学家、纳尔逊的传记作家，
describes the Royal Navy as the most successful fighting service the world had ever seen. Adam Nicholson, who wrote a brilliant book, Men of Honour, about Trafalgar, calls it the most effective maritime killing machine in the world. And I think that the Royal Navy obviously lies at the heart of the story. And as you say, I think we're so familiar with the idea of Britannia ruling the waves, the idea that Britain was a naval power, that it's good to look at how that came about, because actually, there was nothing inevitable about it for centuries and centuries. Britain did not rule the waves. I mean, it was hopeless when it came to kind of controlling its own waters, let alone the waters of Europe and the world beyond. And the story of how that happens is obviously an absolutely fundamental part of Trafalgar and indeed the french and spanish fleets that fight on the other side of trafalgar
将皇家海军描述为世界上见过的最成功的战斗勤务。亚当·尼科尔森写了一本关于特拉法尔加的精彩著作《荣誉之人》，称其为世界上最高效的海上杀戮机器。我认为皇家海军显然处于这个故事的核心。正如你所说，我认为我们对不列颠统治海洋的概念、英国是一个海军强国的概念已经如此熟悉，以至于回顾这一切是如何实现的会很有益，因为实际上，几个世纪以来，这一切绝非必然。英国并没有统治海洋。我的意思是，当涉及到控制它自己的水域时，它简直无可救药，更不用说欧洲的水域和更广阔的世界了。这一切是如何发生的，显然是特拉法尔加故事中极其基础的一部分，当然，这也是在特拉法尔加另一方作战的法国和西班牙舰队的故事。
we should just set the scene in the geopolitics of what's going on in so 1805 is the year i suppose it ranks like 1588 the year of the spanish armada uh 1940 the year of the battle of britain as a year when britain faces invasion by a foreign force. The question of how credible a threat that actually was is something that we'll come to in due course. But that is part of the mythology, isn't it? That 1805, Napoleon could have invaded Britain. Yeah, absolutely. So to give people a sense of the sort of the lie of the land,
我们应该先交代一下正在发生的事情的地缘政治背景。所以1805年这一年，我想它的地位堪比1588年（西班牙无敌舰队之年）、1940年（不列颠战役之年），被视为英国面临外敌入侵的一年。这种威胁实际上有多大可信度，是我们稍后会讨论的问题。但这正是神话的一部分，不是吗？即1805年拿破仑本可以入侵英国。是的，绝对如此。所以为了让人们对当时的局势有一个概念，
Britain and France have fought something like seven major wars, think since the 1690s or so yeah so in france they call it the second hundred years war so yeah the first hundred years war in the middle ages but this is a kind of ongoing process of conflicts that just run and run and run and they are increasingly aren't they world wars so there are wars that take place in multiple theaters you know thousands of miles apart and very often very largely kind of i mean there's there are elements that take place in multiple theatres, you know, thousands of miles apart, and often very largely kind of, I mean, there are elements on land, but the Navy is always hugely important. And this is the latest one, and it's been raging since the early 1790s.
英国和法国自1690年代以来大约打了七场大战。是的，所以在法国，他们称之为“第二次百年战争”——中世纪有第一次百年战争，但这是一种持续不断、没完没了的冲突，它们日益演变成世界大战。所以这些战争发生在多个战区，相距数千英里，而且往往在很大程度上——我的意思是，有些因素发生在多个战区，相距数千英里，而且往往在很大程度上——我的意思是，虽然有陆上的成分，但海军始终极其重要。这是最新的一场，而且自1790年代初以来一直在激烈进行。
It's sort of off and on. There are sort of stop-starts, but I think you can see it all as one kind of continuous campaign, ultimately, can't you? And Britain is constantly trying to enlist, to do what it's always done, to try and enlist continental coalitions against Napoleon. Because one of the strange things about Britain is Britain is a world power, but militarily on land, it is not really much of a, yeah, it is a pygmy.
这可以说是时断时续的。虽然有些走走停停，但我想你可以把这一切看作是一场最终连续不断的战役，对吧？英国一直在试图争取，去做它一直以来都在做的事情，试图拉拢欧洲大陆的联盟来对抗拿破仑。因为关于英国的一个奇怪之处在于，英国是一个世界大国，但在陆上军事方面，它其实算不上一个——是的，它是一个侏儒。
Because for reasons we'll go on to discuss, Britain has always invested in its navy rather than its army. So that means Britain needs allies, but it also needs to uphold its side of the bargain, which is to kind of maintain its naval supremacy. Napoleon, so he faces the same strategic dilemma that successive French administrations have faced. They've always struggled to raise enough money to fight on land and at sea. So France is always ending these wars, whatever the result of the war, France is always ending these wars bankrupt. But Napoleon, because he's ruthless, he's rapacious, he plunders countries he occupies,
因为出于我们接下来要讨论的原因，英国一直投资于海军而不是陆军。这意味着英国需要盟友，但它也需要信守承诺，也就是维持其海军优势。拿破仑面临着历届法国政府所面临的相同的战略困境。他们一直难以筹集足够的资金在陆地和海上作战。因此，无论战争结果如何，法国总是以破产告终。但拿破仑由于冷酷无情、贪婪成性，大肆掠夺他占领的国家，
he poses a kind of threat to Britain, I would say, Tom, that no previous French administration has ever posed. Don't you, wouldn't you agree? This is a kind of an existential challenge on a scale that goes beyond the challenges of, I don't know, well, certainly the Nine Years' War, the War of the Spanish Succession, or some of these previous conflicts. Absolutely. Because what, and it's not just Napoleon, it's the Revolutionary Wars as well. What the French Revolution does is to put the whole of the French patrie into arms. So it's this idea of total war is born with the French Revolution. And it takes the British, I think, a few years to appreciate what they're up against. I mean, it takes all the kind of ancien regime nations of Europe time to realize what has been born in France.
汤姆，我认为他给英国构成了以往任何法国政府都未曾构成的威胁。难道你不这么认为吗？这是一种超越了——我不知道，当然超越了九年战争、西班牙王位继承战或之前某些冲突的——这种规模的存在主义挑战。绝对如此。因为——不仅仅是拿破仑，还有革命战争也是如此。法国大革命所做的是让整个法国祖国武装起来。因此，全面战争的理念随法国大革命而诞生。我认为英国花了好几年时间才意识到他们所面对的是什么。我的意思是，欧洲所有旧制度国家都需要时间来意识到法国孕育出了什么。
And also quickly, a quick point, Tom, a really important point. France is a leviathan. Much larger population, isn't it? Yeah, I think it's got something like 27 million people. Britain's got about 11, is it? 11 million. Yeah. So, I mean, now we think of France and Britain as equivalent.
还有一个简短的要点，汤姆，一个非常重要的要点。法国是一个利维坦。人口多得多，不是吗？是的，我想它大约有2700万人口。英国大约有1100万，是吗？1100万。是的。所以，现在我们认为法国和英国是势均力敌的。
They are not equivalent in population. And, you know, obviously that suggests an economic potential at the dawn of the 19th century. So for Britain, this is something of an uphill struggle. Yes. So Britain, when the Revolutionary Wars break out in 1793, does what Britain has always done throughout the 18th century, which is essentially to pay continental allies to take on the French army. And it, you know, it's kind of diplomacy. It's, you know, all those board games where you have different players and you're all kind of teaming up with one another and stabbing each other in the back. Britain's always been
它们在人口上并不对等。而且，很显然，这表明了19世纪初的经济潜力。所以对英国来说，这是一场相当艰难的斗争。是的。因此，当1793年革命战争爆发时，英国做了它在整个18世纪一直在做的事情，那就是基本上花钱收买欧洲大陆的盟友去与法国军队作战。而且，这是一种外交手段，你知道的，就像那些桌游一样，你有不同的玩家，你们都互相结盟，然后在背后捅刀子。英国一直非常擅长这一点。
very good at that. But the problem is, is that the sheer scale of the armies that the French revolutionary state can command are so enormous and the passions that have been unleashed are so intense that they kind of sweep away the Austrians and the Prussians and everybody. And Britain finds herself to her consternation, basically facing a continent where there are no allies to be had. And so therefore, her only option if she is to train her independence is to rely on the Navy and to basically hope that something will turn up process of wars throughout the 1790s culminating the peace of amiens in 1801 but everyone knows this is basically kind of half time isn't it yeah and britain's sense that france now under napoleon is too restless too dangerous too much of a threat is focused by the refusal of
但问题是，法国革命政权所能调动的军队规模如此庞大，被释放的情绪如此强烈，以至于他们席卷了奥地利、普鲁士和所有人。英国惊恐地发现，自己基本上面对的是一个找不到任何盟友的欧洲大陆。因此，如果她要维护自己的独立，唯一的选择就是依靠海军，并基本上希望事情会有所转机。1790年代的一系列战争在1801年的《亚眠和约》中达到了高潮，但所有人都知道这基本上只是中场休息，对吧？是的，英国感觉到法国现在在拿破仑的统治下过于焦躁、过于危险、威胁太大，这一情绪由于英国拒绝
britain to return the island of malta that napole seized from the Knights of Malta, this kind of ancient chivalric order. The British had then taken in turn. And under the terms of the Treaty of Amiens, Britain was going to return, you know, it was going to give Malta up. But she refuses to do that because by now, Britain's naval power means that it's not just enough to have forces in the Channel or even the Atlantic, but has to be in the Mediterranean as well. And so therefore, they're not going to do it. And that is what precipitates the return to war. Britain under the governance of Pitt, Pitt the Younger, who's Prime Minister, he is returning to a kind of more traditional British policy. He is trying to get Austria, Russia on board. Napoleon realises that he can knock Austria or Russia out easily. He has
归还拿破仑从马耳他骑士团（这个古老的骑士团）手中夺取的马耳他岛而变得更加集中。英国人随后又将其夺回。根据《亚眠和约》的条款，英国本应归还——它本打算放弃马耳他。但她拒绝这样做，因为此时英国的海上力量意味着，仅在海峡或甚至大西洋拥有兵力已经不够了，还必须在地中海部署兵力。因此，他们不打算这么做。正是这一点加速了战争的重启。在皮特（小皮特，时任首相）的领导下，英国正在恢复一种更传统的英国政策。他正试图争取奥地利和俄罗斯的支持。拿破仑意识到他可以轻松击溃奥地利或俄罗斯。他有
the manpower to do that. He has the manpower to do that. He has the military genius to do that. He has the resources to do that. But that if he's going to win the war, he has to knock Britain out. And so that by 1805 is the situation. That is the strategic decision that Napoleon has arrived at, that he has to get troops across the channel to Britain. And that is essentially the state of play. And it's Napoleon himself who comes up with this phrase, describing the war between France and Britain as the war between an elephant and a whale. But of course, another very, very popular analogy is the war between Rome, the military power, and Carthage, this commercial mercantilist naval power
足够的人力做到这一点。他有足够的人力做到这一点。他有军事天才做到这一点。他有资源做到这一点。但如果他想赢得这场战争，他必须击溃英国。所以到1805年，这就是当时的形势。这就是拿破仑得出的战略决定，他必须把军队运送到海峡对岸的英国。这基本上就是当时的比赛状态。而且正是拿破仑自己想出了这个词组，将法英之间的战争描述为大象与鲸鱼之间的战争。当然，另一个非常非常受欢迎的比分类比是罗马（军事强国）与迦太基（这个最终被击败的商业重商主义海军强国）之间的战争。
that ends up being defeated. Well, Napoleon's already modelling himself on a Roman emperor, isn't he? Yes. He's got all the trappings. Well, he is an emperor, isn't he? He's previously been the first consul and now he's the emperor. Exactly. So that suits him. So just on Napoleon and his strategy, people often think, don't they,
好吧，拿破仑已经在把自己塑造为一个罗马皇帝了，不是吗？是的。他拥有所有的外在特征。好吧，他本来就是个皇帝，不是吗？他之前是第一执政，现在他是皇帝。没错。所以这很符合他的心意。就拿破仑和他的战略而言，人们经常认为，
that in 1805 the French were poised to invade Britain. And there's this sort of image, you know. I mean, actually, we did a podcast, Tom, very recently, which I recommend to the listeners, about a history of France in 10 films with Muriel Zaga, who was brilliant. And at the beginning of that podcast, I quoted from Russell Crowe as Jack Aubrey in the film Master and Commander. And he says, do you want a guillotine and Piccadilly?
在1805年，法军已经蓄势待发准备入侵英国。有这样一种形象，你知道的。其实，汤姆，我们最近做了一期播客，我向听众推荐这部播客，是关于通过10部电影看法国历史的，嘉宾是表现出色的穆里尔·扎加（Muriel Zaga）。在那期播客的开头，我引用了电影《怒海争锋》中拉塞尔·克劳饰演的杰克·奥布里的话。他说，
Do you want to have that raggedy arse Napoleon as your king? And all this stuff. That probably wouldn't have happened though, would it? Do you think? That's not really Napoleon's plan. I think, don't you think Napoleon's plan is just to cripple Britain as a naval rival, to smash up its dockyards, all that stuff?
你想要吉洛汀和皮卡迪利广场吗？你想要那个衣衫褴褛的拿破仑当你的国王吗？诸如此类的话。但这可能不会发生，对吧？你觉得呢？那并不是拿破仑真正的计划。我不认为——难道你不认为拿破仑的计划只是削弱英国作为海军对手的实力、砸毁其造船厂等等吗？
That's what Napoleon says. And that's what his marshals in later years say the plan was, that it wasn't to occupy britain it was to destroy its naval resources and that is due trip you know that reflects the fact that napoleon understands that what enables britain to withstand him is the incredible resources that over the course of 150 years the royal navy has built up and has made the royal navy into into this kind of this killing machine a force that is something by the standards of the age something new i mean um something radical lethal and and potentially globes straddling yes absolutely absolutely
拿破仑就是这么说的。他后来的元帅们也说当时的计划就是这样，重点不是占领英国，而是摧毁其海军资源，这反映出拿破仑明白，使英国能够抵挡他的是皇家海军在150年间建立起来的惊人资源，正是这些资源将皇家海军塑造成了这样一台杀戮机器，一股按那个时代的标准来看是崭新的力量——一种激进的、致命的、并且有可能跨越全球的力量。绝对如此，绝对如此。
france cannot afford to invest in the fleet and this to the same degree that britain does because it has obviously land borders that britain you know Britain, it's now the United Kingdom of Great Britain, doesn't have. So the French have to invest in their military. The British, as you've said, they don't have armed forces that are capable of facing up to this. They've periodically kind of land troops in the Netherlands or whatever, and they get beaten out. And so that means that the Royal Navy is the only possible way that Britain can continue fighting. And that's what makes it so significant. So I completely agree that we cannot begin to look or explain the Battle of Trafalgar without looking at the Royal Navy and the deep history that has led us to this context in 1805, where it is a maritime killing force of an order that has never existed
法国无力像英国那样在很大程度上投资于舰队，因为它显然拥有英国（现在是大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国）所没有的陆地边界。因此，法国人必须投资于他们的军事力量。正如你所说的那样，英国没有能够正面抗衡这种力量的武装部队。他们曾定期在荷兰等地登陆军队，但都被赶了出去。这意味着皇家海军是英国继续战斗的唯一可能途径。这也是它如此重要的原因。所以我完全同意，如果不审视皇家海军以及引领我们走向1805年这一背景的深厚历史，我们就无法开始审视或解释特拉法尔加海战——在这一背景下，它是一支前所未有的海上杀戮力量。
before now i know you have you're very very excited about tracing the origins of this back to back to cromwell and peeps yeah so so you sent me a whole load of notes it's full of stuff about the battle of lowestoft against the dutch in the 1660s these are complete lies i don't know what the battle of lowestoft is but. Dominic, I would say that actually the origins of Britain's identification with the Royal Navy goes back even beyond Cromwell. It goes back to Drake.
现在我知道你非常非常兴奋地想要将这一切的起源追溯到克伦威尔和佩皮斯。是的，所以你给我发了一整堆笔记，里面全是关于1660年代对荷兰的洛斯托夫特海战的内容……这些完全是谎言，我不知道什么是洛斯托夫特海战，但是……
Not to Alfred the Great, Tom. No, not to Alfred the Great, although I'm sure we'll touch on that as well. But it's this idea that kind of exists inchoately in the British imagination. I should probably say the English imagination because, of course, Drake was an English admiral.
汤姆，我要说的是，实际上英国人对皇家海军的认同其起源甚至超越了克伦威尔。可以追溯到德雷克。
But it was Protestant ships that had enabled England under Queen Elizabeth to defy continental and Catholic despotism. And so the Navy is seen as being the embodiment of Protestant liberty against the shadow of continental autocracy. And it's pretty easy when you have that in your imaginings to see to pay for it. Lots of people in Parliament know nothing about the Navy, but they know they're vaguely in favour of it because it's Protestant and it's the embodiment of liberty. Unlike armies, which are seen as being sinister, continental, despotic. Exactly. There is a profound distrust in British and indeed English and Scottish before that history of the idea of a standing army controlled by the king, because that is perceived as the tool of Catholic absolutist monarchs. Whereas there's this perception that runs right through the 18th century, that a navy almost inherently, and the Royal Navy par excellence epitomizes this,
不是阿尔弗雷德大帝，汤姆？不，不是阿尔弗雷德大帝，尽管我确信我们也会顺便谈到这一点。但这是一种在英国人的想象中隐约存在的理念。我可能应该说英格兰人的想象，因为当然，德雷克是一位英格兰海军上将。
a navy is the sort of bulwark of liberty that free thinking protestant men will serve on ships whereas if they're wearing you know the uniforms of a land army they are merely the slaves of a despot and i mean people absolutely you see that in cartoons you see that as we'll come on to in songs in popular culture i mean the navy is embedded in in britain's sense of its own identity you could argue tom we'll come on to this again as well that the Navy is embedded in Britain's sense of its own identity. You could argue, Tom, we'll come on to this as well, that the Navy is more than anything else, the British institution, because it's obviously it's great rise really coincides with the invention of Great Britain as a sovereign country. But I think you could go even further than that
正是新教战舰使伊丽莎白女王统治下的英格兰能够抗衡欧洲大陆和天主教的专制统治。因此，海军被视为对抗大陆专制阴影的新教自由的化身。当你的脑海中有这种想法时，为它付费就变得相当容易了。议会中的许多人对海军一无所知，但他们知道自己隐约支持它，因为它是新教的，是自由的化身。这与被视为阴险的、大陆的、专制的陆军不同。完全正确。英国以及在此之前的英格兰和苏格兰的历史中，对由国王控制的常备军的概念存在一种根深蒂固的不信任，因为这被视为天主教专制君主的工具。然而，贯穿整个18世纪的一种看法是，海军几乎生来就是如此，而皇家海军更是其中的典范。海军是自由的堡垒，
and say that in a way, the Royal Navy isn't just a reflection of modern Britain. It helps to create it. Yeah, agreed. Because the simple fact, it's unbelievably expensive. So it's equivalent to about a third of the British government's total annual expenditure. I mean, that is an enormous amount of money. And to raise that money, you need the kind of the frameworks of fiscal responsibility that the current British government stands heir to.
思想自由的新教男人将在船上服役，而如果他们穿着陆军的制服，他们就只是专制君主的奴隶。我的意思是，人们绝对——你在漫画中可以看到这一点，正如我们稍后会讲到的，在流行文化的歌曲中也能看到这一点——海军已经融入了英国对其自身身份的认同之中。你可以这样认为，汤姆，我们稍后也会谈到这一点，海军比其他任何事物都更能代表英国的机构，因为它伟大的崛起确实与大不列颠作为主权国家的诞生不谋而合。但我认为你可以走得更远，
So I found it quite depressing reading about, you know, how in the 18th century... You don't trust Liz Truss with the Royal Navy, Tom? You know, the national debt and the kind of the tools of borrowing and lending
并认为在某种程度上，皇家海军不仅仅是现代英国的反映。它有助于塑造现代英国。是的，完全同意。因为很简单的事实是，它贵得不可思议。因此，它相当于英国政府年度总支出的三分之一左右。我的意思是，这是一笔巨额资金。为了筹集这笔资金，你需要当前英国政府所继承的那种财政责任框架。
that the British state creates. And which essentially provide the kind of the tools of borrowing and lending that the British state creates, and which essentially provide the kind of, you know, the foundations for the entire global economic system to this day. Well, quasi-quarting, if you're listening, please start taking notes now. But the need to fund the Navy is a crucial part of what enables those kind of frameworks to exist. So that's why in some ways the Battle of Trafalgar is the culmination of a story that is a story not just about, you know, sailors fighting at sea.
所以我发现阅读关于……你不会把皇家海军交给莉兹·特拉斯吧，汤姆？——你知道的，国债以及英国国家创造的借贷工具。
It's a story about finance and it's a story about the invention of a modern state. Modern state, yes. Now, we should probably take a break, shouldn't we, Tom? And then come back and talk a little bit more about the Navy.
这基本上为英国国家创造了借贷工具，并从根本上为直至今日的整个全球经济体系奠定了基础。好吧，如果伊恩·夸特尼（Ian Quartney）你在听，请现在开始做笔记。但为海军提供资金的需求，是促使这些框架得以存在的关键部分。因此，在某些方面，特拉法尔加海战不仅是一场关于水手在海上战斗的故事，更是金融的故事和现代国家发明的故事。现代国家，是的。
Because I have some very interesting naval facts for you, which I think... I can't wait. I know you'll find that very exciting. So we shall see you with our naval facts after you, which I think I can't wait. I think you'll find that very exciting. So we shall see you with our naval facts after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard
现在，我们大概应该休息一下，对吧，汤姆？然后回来多谈谈海军。因为我有一些非常有趣的海军冷知识要告诉你，我想……我迫不及待了。我知道你会觉得这非常令人兴奋。所以休息过后，我们会带着海军冷知识与大家见面，我想……我迫不及待了。我想你会觉得这非常令人兴奋。所以休息过后，我们会带着海军冷知识与大家见面。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·
Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
奥斯曼，我们联袂主持《娱乐余音》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和优先购买现场门票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland, do you know the origins of the phrase a slush fund? Do you have a slush fund personally um i do because you told me about it yesterday but i i will pretend that i don't know dominic tell me what the origins of the phrase slush fund so a a cook on board a royal navy ship he's he's basically a boiling um salted meat that they've got this disgusting sounding salted meat and as the water boils the fat separates from the meat,
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。汤姆·霍兰，你知道“slush fund”（贿赂基金/小金库）这个词组的起源吗？你自己个人有小金库吗？嗯，我有的，因为你昨天刚跟我说过，但我会假装我不知道。多米尼克，告诉我这个词组的起源是什么？所以，皇家海军军舰上的厨师，他基本上是在煮盐肉——他们有这种听起来很恶心腌制盐肉——当水沸腾时，脂肪会从肉中分离出来，
and it forms this sort of layer of scum. The cook would ladle that layer off, the scum, and he would put it, I don't know, in a bucket or something, and people called it slush. It was useful because it's fat, so they can use it for waterproofing ropes, and they can make candles from it, and the cook is allowed to sell it um privately and make money from it's one of the perks of being a ship's cook and that therefore is called his slush fund
它会形成一层浮渣。厨师会把那层浮渣撇下来，把它放进一个桶里什么的，人们称之为“slush”（油腻的残渣/杂质）。这很有用，因为它是脂肪，所以他们可以用它来防水绳索，还可以用它来做蜡烛，而且厨师被允许私下出售它并以此赚钱——这是当船上厨师的福利之一，因此这被称为他的“slush fund”（油渣基金/小金库）。
and i think we use that phrase all the time we don't know where it comes from and actually you know what there are tons of phrases that are like this so i read a book called empire of the deep by ben wilson all about the raw navy and he has this wonderful section where he talks about, you know, obviously there are some that are very obvious. So, Tom, on this podcast, sometimes you are all at sea. Sometimes I have to say you're sailing very close to the wind. I'm worried, obviously, that you'll walk out and leave me high and dry. But if you don't, then it'll just be plain sailing.
我想我们一直在使用这个词组，却不知道它来自哪里。实际上，你知道吗，有很多词组都像这样：我读了一本由本·威尔逊（Ben Wilson）写的名为《深海帝国》（Empire of the Deep）的书，全关于皇家海军，其中有一个很棒的章节，他谈到了——显然有些词组非常明显。所以，汤姆，在这档播客中，有时你完全迷失方向（all at sea）。有时我不得不说你做事非常冒险（sailing very close to the wind）。我很担心，当然，你会一走了之，把我扔在一旁不管（high and dry）。但如果你不这样，那一切就会一帆风顺（plain sailing）。
And there are some guests to whom we would give a wide berth. There are some guests for whom we'd push the boat out. There are some loose cannons. Yeah, there are some guests to whom we would give a wide berth there are some guests for whom we'd push the boat out that's our loose cannons yeah there are some loose cannons sometimes we have to press gang them into appearing on the rest of history sometimes we have to give them a shot across the bows we do sometimes you're in full flow and i have to take the wind out of your sails or tell me to pipe down i tell you to pipe down, exactly. So you pipe, don't you? If people, you give an order for men to calm down through the pipes. I mean, some people would say we're just sitting here chewing the fat, Tom. Okay, so what, Dominic, what is the cut of your jib? That's a navel, isn't it?
有些嘉宾我们会敬而远之（give a wide berth）。有些嘉宾我们会全力以赴（push the boat out）。还有一些是不受控制的人（loose cannons）。是的，有些嘉宾我们会敬而远之，有些嘉宾我们会全力以赴，那就是我们的“loose cannons”（不受控制的人/定时炸弹）。有时我们不得不强征（press-gang）他们来《历史余音》亮相。有时我们不得不给他们一点警告（shot across the bows）。我们确实会这样。有时你正滔滔不绝，我不得不打消你的锐气（take the wind out of your sails）或者叫你闭嘴。我叫你闭嘴，没错。所以你会吹哨，对吧？如果人们——你通过吹哨发出让大家安静下来的命令。我的意思是，有些人会说我们只是坐在这里闲聊（chewing the fat），汤姆。好吧，那么，多米尼克，你的风格（cut of your jib）是什么样的？那是海军术语，对吧？
Yeah. So a jib is a, as a some form, I think it's some sort of sail. I mean, basically, I think it's fair to say some listeners regular listeners will remember that we did a podcast about the portuguese age of exploration and our explanation for portuguese naval technology was they had was it triangular sails was that the yes so but i think what all this tells you and the fact that there are so many of these things so learning the ropes hand over fist hard and fast well okay so learning the ropes dominic yeah learning the right i've gone on record i'm not interested in rope and i remain uninterested in rope and yeah that is uh it doesn't
是的。所以“jib”（三角帆）是一种——某种形式的帆。我的意思是，基本上，我认为可以这样说，一些听众——老听众会记得我们曾做过一期关于葡萄牙大航海时代的播客，我们对葡萄牙海军技术的解释是他们拥有——是三角形帆吗？——是的。但我认为这一切所向你表明的，以及有这么多这类词汇的事实——比如学习绳结技术（learning the ropes）、轻而易举（hand over fist）、毫不迟疑（hard and fast）——好吧，学习绳结技术，多米尼克，是的，学习绳结技术——我已经公开说过，我对绳索不感兴趣，而且我对绳索依然不感兴趣，是的，那——没关系，
matter i don't need to know about ropes but the point is is that british midshipmen did they did so it had become a very professional service and the contrast you'll be delighted to hear is with the french the french in the french navy they weren't interested in learning the ropes that was seen as the class a yeah they were interested they were interested in learning abstract principles i saw that and you i saw that in your notes that they were the french were only only interested in abstract nouns very like today yes. Yes, I thought you'd enjoy that. Whereas British officers, even if they were quite well born, so one of the sons of George III went to sea as a midshipman. Yes. So where does this come from, Tom? Because the thing is, you mentioned
我不需要了解绳索，关键是英国海军见习军官需要。所以它已经成为一个非常专业的部门。你会高兴地听到，这与法国人形成了对比。法国人——在法国海军中，他们对学习绳结不感兴趣，那被视为A类——是的，他们感兴趣的是学习抽象原则。我看到了，我在你的笔记里看到了，法国人只对抽象名词感兴趣，非常像今天的法国人。是的。是的，我想你会喜欢的。而英国军官，即使他们出身相当高贵——比如乔治三世的一个儿子就作为见习军官出海了。是的。所以这一切源自哪里，汤姆？因为问题在于，你提到了
Drake, but even in the generation after Drake, England is not really a naval power at all. And actually, I would say, well, I say this because i've read other people's books would you say that yeah this is what your research has led you to my close expertise on the subject and my knowledge of triangular sails says to me that actually the real turning point is that it's the middle of the 17th century it's actually the interregnum so it's the the cromwellian period and it's competition it's competition specifically with the dutch so what actually happens and this is a very simplistic way of doing it of describing it and sort of naval historians may be tearing their hair out is that in a way britain keeps losing england keeps losing battles sea battles to the dutch but in the long run it kind of wins the
德雷克，但即使在德雷克之后的几代人中，英格兰实际上根本算不上一个海军强国。而且事实上，我会说——我这么说是因为我读过别人的书——你会说——这正是你的研究所得吗？我对这个主题的深刻专业知识以及我对三角帆的知识告诉我，真正的转折点实际上是17世纪中期，也就是英国共和联邦时期（Interregnum），即克伦威尔时期，并且是与荷兰人的竞争。具体来说，是与荷兰人的竞争。所以实际发生的事情——这是一种非常简单化的描述方式，海军历史学家可能会气得抓狂——在某种程度上，英国不断输掉——英格兰在海战中不断输给荷兰，但在长远来看，它赢得了
competition because all the time it is losing the the Royal Navy is improving, is modernizing, is learning from its opponents. So by the 1660, when you have the restoration, it is already much larger. Cromwell has spent an awful lot of money on the Navy in this sort of competition for trade with Britain's great Protestant commercial rival, which is the Dutch Republic. It has two admirals in particular, Blake and Monk, who are very much into kind of, we need to be more disciplined. It can't be the sort of shambles that it has been for most of our history. And the government is prepared to finance that. And that continues. So it's a great example, actually, the continuity between the Cromwellian period and the restoration, because that continues under Charles II. And James II was Lord High Admiral during the Restoration period. He's very much all about the Navy. So they do two things in particular in the Restoration period. So one is you have peeps and administration, so the creation of a kind of bureaucracy. And the other is professionalization. So it's actually under Charles II
这场竞争，因为在不断失败的同时，皇家海军正在改进、正在现代化、正在向对手学习。因此到了1660年代，随着斯图亚特复辟，它的规模已经大得多。克伦威尔为了争夺与英国伟大的新教商业对手——荷兰共和国的贸易，在海军上花费了大量的资金。它拥有两位杰出的海军上将：布莱克（Blake）和蒙克（Monk），他们非常注重纪律。它不能再像我们大部分历史那样一团糟了。政府准备为此提供资金。这种状况得以延续。因此，克伦威尔时期与复辟时期的连续性就是一个很好的例子，因为这种情况在查理二世统治下得以延续。詹姆斯二世在复辟时期担任过海军大臣。他非常热衷于海军。所以在复辟时期，他们特别做了两件事。一是佩皮斯和行政管理，即建立了一种官僚体制。二是专业化。实际上正是在查理二世统治下，
that naval lieutenants have to pass an exam. And if you think about the British army, so right into the 19th century, it's still a very amateur way of life where you buy your way in. So in the Navy, Charles II describes the Navy as a trade, very telling word. In other words, it's not. It's something you learn a trade and you have to pass an exam to do it. So it's a professional enterprise. And then when you get to the an exam to do it. So it's a professional enterprise. And then when you get to the end of the 17th century, William of Orange and Mary and Anne, obviously now you're in competition with the French. So rather than the Dutch, you're now facing the French who are a real, they are the superpower. And the only way England and Scotland and then Britain can compete is through finance.
海军中尉必须通过考试。如果你想想英国陆军，直到19世纪，它仍然是一种非常业余的生活方式，你可以通过花钱买官来获得军衔。但在海军中，查理二世将海军描述为一种“行业”（trade），这是一个非常说明问题的词。换句话说，它不是。它是一项你必须通过考试才能从事的行业。因此，这是一个专业化的企业。然后当你进入17世纪末，威廉和玛丽以及安妮女王统治时期，显然你现在是在与法国竞争。因此，不再是与荷兰竞争，你现在面对的是真正的超级大国法国。英格兰、苏格兰以及后来的英国能够竞争的唯一途径就是通过金融。
So William brings over these sort of Dutch financial techniques, and now they're being applied on a much grander scale. So the classic one is the Bank of England. The Bank of England is founded in 1694. England is locked in this sort of long struggle against Louis XIV's France. Right away, the Bank of England raises more than a million pounds and an absolutely astronomical sum of money by the standards of the day and more than half of that tom was spent on the royal navy so finance and kind of naval power were absolutely intertwined and in fact even the public are
因此，威廉带来了这些荷兰的金融技术，现在它们正以更大的规模被应用。最典型的例子就是英格兰银行。英格兰银行成立于1694年。英格兰卷入了这场长期对抗路易十四法国的斗争中。英格兰银行一成立就筹集了超过一百万英镑，按当时的标准这是一笔天文数字，其中汤姆有一半以上的资金都花在了皇家海军上。因此，金融与海军力量是密不可分的，事实上，甚至公众也
financing the navy so from 1714 you as an ordinary punter, you as a sort of spec, a small speculator, you can buy a Navy bill, which is traded on the stock exchange, will give you a return of 6% a year. And that presumably is seen as being patriotic, the patriotic option. Absolutely. Absolutely. You think about all the war bonds that, so our American, Australian, Canadian, British listeners, all of these people will remember, in the World Wars, you would buy war bonds to support the war effort. This is exactly what people are doing at the turn of the 18th century, and it is supporting specifically the Navy. So as we enter the 18th century, Britain has a naval bureaucracy. It has the Admiralty Building in Whitehall, offices, people with pieces of paper. And it's also, as time goes on, the Navy becomes absolutely embedded in britain so britain is created in 1707 and the navy is at the center of that because that's all we have we don't
资助海军。所以从1714年起，作为一个普通赌徒，作为一个某种意义上的投机者、小投机客，你可以买一份海军债券，它在证券交易所交易，每年能给你带来6%的回报。这大概被视为一种爱国行为，是爱国者的选择。绝对是。完全正确。想想所有的战争公债，我们的美国、澳大利亚、加拿大、英国听众，所有这些人都会记得，在两次世界大战中，你会购买战争公债来支持战争努力。这正是18世纪初人们所做的事情，它专门用于支持海军。因此，当我们进入18世纪时，英国已经拥有了一套海军官僚体制。它在白厅拥有海军部大楼、办公室和处理文书的人员。随着时间的推移，海军也绝对融入了英国之中。英国是在1707年建立的，而海军正是这一切的核心，因为这就是我们拥有的全部，我们并不
really have an arm i mean i know there's mulberry in the battle of well so regiments are obviously drawn from counties or yeah or regions they're very localized whereas the royal navy people come from all over the place exactly exactly so the anthem the great Navy, people come from all over the place. Exactly. Exactly. So the anthem, the great anthem that people associate with, apart from God Save the King, the anthem that people associate with this new country, Great Britain, is, of course, Rule Britannia. Britannia Rules the Waves. Yeah. Britannia Rule the Waves.
真的有一支陆我指我知道有马尔伯勒和明登战役，所以军团显然是从各郡或各地区征召的。它们非常地方化，而皇家海军的人则来自四面八方。确实，确实如此。所以这首歌，这首伟大的海军军歌，人们来自四面八方。没错，完全正确。所以这首赞歌，这首人们除了《天佑吾王》之外，与这个新国家——大不列颠联系在一起的伟大赞歌，当然就是《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》。不列颠尼亚统治海洋。对。不列颠尼亚统治海洋。
Exactly. Now, that was sung at a, it was a sort of a play, an opera, a masque, a musical about Alfred the Great. Yeah. About Alfred the Great. Who gets kind of, you know, back projected as the founder of the Royal Navy, which of course he wasn't. No, but this idea, that idea is really important.
没错。这首歌当时是在一演出中唱的一类戏剧、歌剧、假面剧、关于阿尔弗雷德大帝的音乐剧。对。关于阿尔弗雷德大帝的。他被某种程度上（你知道的）被追溯塑造为皇家海军的奠基人，而他当然并非如此。没错，但这种观点，这种观点非常重要。
So in 1740, when the people are watching the Alfred the Great and they're singing Rue Britannia, they are kind of inventing a tradition in which Britain has always been a maritime power and which the Royal Navy of the mid-18th century is sort of being projected as the culmination of a process that has taken almost a thousand years. I mean, we think of the Navy, I guess, because we're living in the sort of shadow of it. You know, we probably think, and many of the listeners will think of the Navy as an incredibly traditional, old-fashioned institution, full of weird rituals and phrases. But in the 18th century,
所以在1740年，当人们观看《阿尔弗雷德大帝》并高唱《统治吧，不列颠尼亚》时，他们实际上是在创造一种传统：在这种传统中，英国一直是一个海上强国，18世纪中叶的皇家海军则被描绘成一个历时近千年的发展过程的顶峰。我的意思是，我们可能会想到海军，因为我们生活在它的某种阴影之下。你知道，我们可能会认为，许多听众也会认为海军是一个极其传统、老派的机构，充满了奇怪的仪式和习语。但在18世纪，
the Royal Navy, I would say, represents the acme of modernity. Completely. With its bureaucracy, with its finance, all those things. Yes. By 1805, the Royal Navy is, I mean, there hasn't been a kind of dramatic change in the way that there is with, say, with the development of steam power. Techniques for fighting battles are basically the same as they've been pretty much for 150 years. So in that sense, nothing radically has changed. In Victory, there's been 74 gunships, aren't they?
皇家海军，我想说，代表了现代性的巅峰。完全如此。凭借其官僚体制、财政以及所有这些事物。是的。到了1805年，皇家海军——我的意思是，它的作战方式并没有发生那种剧烈变化，比如蒸汽动力发展所带来的那种改变。海战的技术基本上和过去150年左右大同小异。所以从这个意义上说，没有什么根本性的改变。“胜利”号上装备了74门火炮，对吧？
They came in from the 1750s. Yes, but HMS Victory, Nelson's flagship, is about 40 years old at the Battle of Trafalgar. And Nelson himself, who becomes a midshipman before the outbreak of the Revolutionary Wars, lots of the admirals who fight in Nelson's Navy, the captains have come of age during the war of American independence. But essentially, the fighting techniques haven't radically altered. Having said that, however, I think that there are two ways in which the Royal Navy is, as you say, the kind of the embodiment of the future. The first is that although the fundamentals of fighting naval battles and fighting naval campaigns have remained the same, decades and decades of having the Royal Navy at the heart of the British state means that the funding, the understanding, the provisioning, the manning of this force has been unbelievably well streamlined. So in contrast, say, to France, which has these periodic bankruptcies,
它们是从18世纪50年代开始出现的。是的，但是纳尔逊的旗舰“胜利”号在特拉法加海战时已经有大约40年的历史了。纳尔逊本人——他在独立战争爆发前成为一名见习军官，在纳尔逊的海军中作战的许多海军上将、舰长们，都是在美国独立战争期间成熟起来的。但从根本上说，作战技术并没有发生根本性的改变话虽如此，然而，我认为皇家海军在两个方面正如你所说的那样，是未来的某种化身。首先，尽管海战和海军战役的基本原理保持不变，但几十年来皇家海军一直是英国国家核心，这意味着这支部队的资金筹措、后勤理解、物资供应和人员配备已经变得难以置信地精简。因此，相比之下，比如说法国，它历经周期性的破产，
lacks the kind of bureaucratic infrastructure, lacks the naval dockyards that Britain has. And so it's a much more kind of staccato process. Ships get knocked out, they have to start again almost from scratch. In Britain, there is this kind of continuity of tradition, which means that the putting to sea of ships has become something incredibly fluent. And I think the other thing is that over the course of the decades that precede Trafalgar, in all kinds of ways, everything to do with the Navy has been tightened, has been streamlined, has been made more efficient and in a way trafalgar is the ultimate demonstration of the success of that process well i mean if you think about in the seven years war tom in the seven years war which is a sort of generation or two
缺乏英国所拥有的那种官僚基础设施，缺乏英国那样的海军造船厂。所以这是一个更加断断续续的过程。舰艇被毁后，他们几乎不得不从头开始。而在英国，这种传统的延续意味着军舰的出海变成了一件极其流畅的事情。我认为另一件事是，在特拉法加战役前的几十年里，在方方面面，与海军相关的一切都得到了收紧、精简和效率提升，某种程度上，特拉法加战役正是这一过程成功的终极展示。好吧，我的意思是，如果你想想七年战争，汤姆，在七年战争中，那大约是一代或两代人
earlier they had started to provision ships with fresh vegetables i mean it sounds like such a boring trivial point of course it's not if you're on board the ship. So they are sending not just sort of carrots and beer and cabbages, but they have ships with live cattle on them that they are sending hundreds of miles across the world. And pigs. Yeah, to resupply the fleet. I mean, that is, if you think about the logistical operation, you know, in a world where everything is done on paper and handwritten on paper, just to organize all that to have everything in place at the right time and for the ships to communicate with each
以前的事了，他们开始用新鲜蔬菜为船只供应给养。我的意思是，这听起来像是一个无聊且微不足道的问题，但如果你身在船上，它当然就不微不足道了。所以他们运送的不仅是胡萝卜、啤酒和卷心菜，他们的船上还载着活牛，运送到世界各地数百英里之外。还有猪。是的，用来给舰队补给。我的意思是，如果你考虑一下后勤运作，你知道，在一个一切都依靠纸张和手写来完成的世界里，仅仅为了组织这一切，在正确的时间把所有东西都准备就绪，让船只相互沟通，
other for them to rendezvous at the right place at the right point that takes an enormous amount of bureaucratic organization when you mention the dockyards the dockyards themselves are like they're like manufacturers aren't they well just to stick to the provisioning and also the cleanliness, because good provisions and washing down the ships are absolutely integrated. A healthy crew on a ship is a well-fed crew. And really, that is a product of the 1780s. So the decade of defeat at the hands of the American rebels. But Britain, the Royal Navy comes out of that with a very, very clear understanding that you win wars by having healthy, well-fed sailors. And so that's when they rumble the fact that if you eat lime, then you won't get scurvy. So after the Battle of Nile, he comes back to Sicily.
让它们在正确的地点和时刻会合，这需要庞大的官僚组织工作。当你提到造船厂时，造船厂本身就跟制造厂一样，不是吗？嗯，单就后勤供应和清洁工作而言，因为良好的给养和冲洗船只绝对是密不可分的。船上健康的船员就是吃得饱的船员。真的，那是18世纪80年代的产物。那是被美国叛军打败的十年。但英国，皇家海军从中得出了一个非常非常清晰的认识：赢得战争靠的是拥有健康、饱食的水手。所以正是在那个时候，他们弄明白了如果你吃青柠，你就不会得坏血病。所以在尼罗河战役之后，他回到了西西里。
He's hanging out with Lady Hamilton, all that kind of stuff. But he's also busy setting up a contract to buy 30,000 gallons of lemon juice a year yeah and in hna4 the year before trafalgar you know the guy who is provisioning his fleet is sourcing food as far away as south russia i can't remember which writer it is i think it might be it might be nelson's amazing biographer john sugden i think it is who says nelson's men at the battle of trafalgar were literally the healthiest britons alive nam roger who's um about the command of, who's a book, The Command of the Ocean, is a brilliant, I mean, it's the definitive history of the emergence of the Royal Navy, and it obviously includes the Nelsonian period. Yeah. And he goes on to say that if you're looking
他和汉密尔顿夫人混在一起，诸如此类的事情。但他也很忙，正忙着签合同购买每年3万加仑的柠檬汁。是的，在海娜4（应为1804年）——特拉法加战役的前一年，你知道，为他的舰队提供补给的那个人，甚至从远至南俄罗采购食物。我不记得是哪位作家了，我想可能是纳尔逊的出色传记作家约翰·萨格登（John Sugden），我想是他说过，特拉法加战役中的纳尔逊手下简直是当时活着的、最健康的英国人。南·罗杰（Nam Roger），他那本关于指挥权的著作《海洋的指挥权》（The Command of the Ocean），是一部极其精彩的著作，我的意思是，它是皇家海军崛起的最权威历史，其中显然包括纳尔逊时期。是的。他接着说，如果你着眼于
at the Victorian period, and you want to identify the origins of public health movements, and even the science of epidemiology, then you look at the Royal Navy, because this is where the British state has a stake in developing this. And what Roger also says, fascinatingly, is he casts Britain's dockyards entered the industrial age 100 years before the rest of the country. So that's kind of an amazing idea that Portsmouth and Plymouth and Chatham are these kind of centres for industrialisation long before it's starting to develop elsewhere in Britain, let alone the rest of Europe or the world. When William Pitt the Elder, of course, becomes Earl of Chatham, that's a badge of modernity because of places like Chatham and Portsmouth, certainly by the turn of the 19th century.
维多利亚时代，想要找出公共卫生运动甚至流行病学科学的起源，那么你就得看皇家海军，因为正是在这里，英国国家利益攸关地参与了这些领域的发展。罗杰还迷人地指出，他认为英国的造船厂比全国其他地区早100年进入了工业时代。所以这是一个令人惊叹的概念：朴茨茅斯、普利茅斯和查塔姆在英国其他地区，更不用说欧洲其他地区或世界其他地区开始发展工业化之前很久，就已经成为工业化的中心。当老威廉·皮特成为查塔姆伯爵时，这正是由于查塔姆和朴茨茅斯这样地方的存在，至少在19世纪之交，这成了一种现代性的标志。
I mean, effectively, is it not some people, NAM Roger maybe talks about this as the world's first assembly line? Yeah. So that's a guy called Samuel Bentham. He's appointed the Inspector General of Naval Works in 1796. And he goes in to Portsmouth and he makes it essentially the most industrially sophisticated location in the entire world. So he builds vastly deeper docks that can take bigger ships. He is developing the use of steam engines to drain the docks, to power sawmills and rolling mills and all these kinds of things. And you've got these block mills that are invented by Mark Brunel, who's the father of Isambard, Kingdom Brunel, manufactured by a guy called Henry Maudsley. And amazingly, so these are, I think, by historians of the Industrial Revolution cast as the world's first assembly line of machine tools. And
我的意思是，实际上，这难道不是——有些人，南·罗杰可能谈到过这一点——被称为世界上第一条装配线吗？是的。所以这是一个叫塞缪尔·边沁（Samuel Bentham）的人。他在1796年被任命为海军工程总监。他来到朴茨茅斯，基本上把它建成了整个世界上工业化程度最高的地方。因此，他建造了更深的船坞以容纳更大的船只；他开发了蒸汽机的使用来排干船坞、为锯木厂和轧机以及所有这类事情提供动力。这里还有由马克·布鲁内尔（Isambard Kingdom Brunel的父亲）发明、由亨利·莫兹利（Henry Maudsley）制造的滑轮滑车厂。令人惊叹的是，这些机器被工业革命历史学家视为世界上第一条机床装配线，而且
amazingly, they only stopped working in 1983. So after the Falklands War. That's incredible. Unbelievable. And this is happening at the end of the 18th century. Yeah, in the age of bonnets. And as we discovered in our fashion podcast, the age of the rise of the corset and the trouser, but also of the assembly line. So Tom, the parallel here, right, to sort of widen the picture out,
令人惊叹的是，它们直到1983年才停止运转。也就是马岛战争之后。这太不可思议了。难以置信。而这一切发生在18世纪末。是的，在女帽的时代。正如我们在时尚播客中发现的那样，这是紧身胸衣和长裤兴起的时代，同时也是装配线的时代。所以，汤姆，这里的相似之处在于，为了放宽视野，
the parallel here, you would argue, is with the role of the world wars in the 20th century in driving all kinds of development, but also the role, I suppose, of American defense spending in driving the rise of digital technology, the internet, all suppose, of American defence spending in driving the rise of digital technology, the internet, all these kinds of things. Here is a perfect example of military technology driving social, cultural and economic change. Yes, but it's also about very small incremental changes. So British gunnery is not massively, it's not revolutionary. It's not so far ahead, say,
这里的相似之处，你可能会说，是20世纪世界大战在推动各类发展方面所起的作用，但我想，这也类似于美国国防开支在推动数字技术、互联网以及所有这些事物崛起方面所起的作用。这是一个军事技术推动社会、文化和经济变革的完美例证。是的，但这也是关于非常小的渐进式变革。因此，英国的火炮技术并不是大规模的，它不是革命性的。它并没有遥遥领先于——比方说，
a French or Spanish gunnery has to be on another planet. But there are incremental changes. So there's a company called the Caron Company outside Glasgow that develops these new guns called Caronades, which are very short range. So they can't come across. I'm listening to you talking about gunnery, Tom, man. But so the key there is that you have to get up close. And thanks to British rule in India, they now have access to much better saltpeter, the French or the Spanish have.
法国或西班牙的火炮技术必须达到另一个星球的水平。但有一些渐进式的变化。所以在格拉斯哥郊外有一家名为卡伦的公司（Caron Company），他们开发了一种名为卡隆炮（Caronades）的新型火炮，射程非常短。所以它们无法跨越——我在听你谈论火炮，汤姆，天哪。但关键在于，你必须贴近敌舰。而且由于英国在印度的统治，他们现在能够获得比法国或西班牙好得多的硝石。
So it's about kind of 20% perhaps more efficient. Again, I can't believe I'm coming up with all this stuff. And the relentless emphasis on discipline and practice. Well, that is key. It's the professionalization, isn't it? Because isn't the argument that we are going to get one day to the Battle of Trafalgar itself? But when we do, the key to it is not that the equipment is better
所以它的效率可能提高了20%左右。同样，我简直不敢相信自己能想出所有这些东西。还有对纪律和演练的不懈强调。嗯，那是关键。这就是职业化，不是吗？因为难道不是有这样一种观点吗：我们终有一天会迎来特拉法加海战本身。但当我们到达那里时，关键并不在于装备更好
or the ships are better. It is simply that the British, the Royal Navy, the men of the Royal Navy are an incredibly well-trained, professionalized fighting machine in ways that their rivals just aren't. So on a French ship, the average is you can fire one broadside from your cannon every four minutes. On a British ship, the best British ships, the most practised British ships, you can get three broadsides in three minutes.
或者船只更好。而仅仅在于英国人，皇家海军，皇家海军的人员是一部极其训练有素、高度职业化的作战机器，而他们的对手根本不是这样。在一艘法国军舰上，平均每四分钟才能从加农炮发射一轮齐射。而在英国军舰上，最优秀的英国军舰上，最熟练的英国军舰上，你可以在三分钟内进行三轮齐射。
Three in three minutes? Yeah. So in addition to that, have current so the british have carronades on all their ships the french and spanish don't if you can get your ships up close your guns are better your gunpowder is better and you can fire at a prodigiously faster rate you're going to cause carnage and that is absolutely key to understanding nelson's strategy at trafalgar and indeed more generally is that you get up close and you blast the shit out of your opponents. Right. That's a technical term.
三分钟三轮？是的。除此之外，还有——所以英国人在所有船只上都装备了卡隆炮，而法军和西军则没有。如果你能把你的船开到近距离，你的火炮更好，火药更好，并且能以惊人的速度开火，你就会造成大屠杀，这对于理解纳尔逊在特拉法加的战略，乃至更广泛的战略，绝对是至关重要的，那就是贴近敌人，把你的对手炸个稀巴烂。没错。这是一个专业术语。
That's a technical, nautical term. Just to leap ahead. I think there's a sense in which people don't appreciate the consequences of all this that you're talking about, Tom. So to give you just a leap ahead to anticipate a second for when we do get to the Battle of Trafalgar. On the day of the battle, the victory, they keep incredibly, I mean, this is a sign of the bureaucratization, they keep incredibly detailed
这是一个专业的航海术语。稍微超前说一下。我认为在某种程度上，人们并没有意识到你所谈论的所有这一切后果，汤姆。所以，为了稍微超前预料一下我们什么时候能到达特拉法加海战。在战斗的那一天，“胜利”号上，他们保持着令人难以置信的——我的意思是，这是官僚化的一种标志，他们保持着极其详细的
records. And they record that they fired 4,243 round shot and 371 double-headed and grape shot, and they threw 4,000 musket balls at their opponents. So that's from one ship. So that gives you some sort of sense of just what a colossal enterprise, equipping a ship, equipping it, training the men to do it, and then actually what a horrific enterprise it is
记录。他们记录了他们发射了4243枚圆弹、371枚双头弹和葡萄弹，并向对手投掷了4000颗滑膛枪弹。这仅仅来自一艘船。所以这让你对组装一艘船、配备它、训练水手去操作它是一项多么庞大的企业，然后实际上在近距离作战又是多么可怕的一场经历，有了一些概念。要做到这一点，你只有拥有国家机器才能办到。所以皮特——这就是为什么在我看来，小皮特显然是英国在整个历史时期中最有效的战争领导人和首相之一，因为他
to be out there fighting at close quarters. And to do that, you can only do that if you've got the state machine. So Pitt, that's why Pitt the Younger, I think to my mind, is clearly one of Britain's most effective war leaders and prime ministers in the whole sweep, because he is
极其擅长通过税收等手段创建为其提供资金的金融机器。你在播客刚开始时用了“全面战争”这个词。这就是英国全面战争的尖兵。没错。因此，皇家海军的舰艇可能是地球上维护得最好的物件，你知道的，人们倾注了更多的心血、关爱和注意力来保持它们的整洁、清洁和装备精良，这是其他任何地方的同类事物都无法比拟的。所以这些绝对是关键所在。但还有更深层的维度，也就是战略和战术上的。我简直不敢相信自己有多像我的——我应该说，你越来越像你的兄弟了
brilliant at creating the financial machine through taxation and stuff that will fund this. You used the phrase at the beginning of the podcast, total war. This is the spearhead of Britain's total war. Right. And so the fact that the ships of the Royal Navy are probably the best maintained objects anywhere on the planet, you know, that more care and love and attention is lavished on keeping them spruce, clean, well-equipped than anything comparable anywhere. So these are absolutely key things. But there's also further dimensions, which is strategic and tactical. And i can't believe how much like my my brother i should say you're turning to your brother i'm sounding because
因为皇家海军不仅磨练了将这些杀戮机器开到水面上的能力，它还开发了如何以最佳效果使用它们的战术。所以在1840年代左右，他们基本上已经研究清楚了，他们需要对英吉利海峡的控制权。这听起来如此显而易见，但在1840年代之前，他们其实并没有完全想通这一点。嗯，英国历史上对海峡的控制能力极其糟糕。这就是为什么人们总是入侵、穿越等等。所以在1840年代，他们开发了一种名为“西部舰队”（Western Squadron）的东西，该舰队驻扎在
the royal navy hasn't just honed its ability to put these kind of killing machines out onto the waters it's also developed techniques for how to use them to best effect so what they have worked out by basically the 1740s is that they need control of the channel. And that sounds so obvious, but they hadn't kind of worked that out up until the 1740s. Well, Britain had historically been abysmal at controlling the channel. That's why people are always invading and crossing and all this sort of stuff. So by the 1740s, they've developed this thing called the Western Squadron, which is based along
南部海岸——也就是朴茨茅斯和普利茅斯，这使得英国不仅能够保持对海峡的控制，还能控制通往海峡的西方航道。而法国人面临的巨大难题是——法国人在他们的海峡海岸沿线缺乏深水港，基本上他们的海军基地布雷斯特（Brest）位于布列塔尼（Brittany）的海角附近。所以这对法国人来说是个问题。朴茨茅斯和普利茅斯对他们来说是极好的港口。但随后在18世纪80年代到90年代革命战争爆发期间，他们的战略愿景得到了进一步的精简。在纳尔逊之前，实际上有两位关键人物，而纳尔逊是他们两人的门徒，他的
the south coast so portsmouth and plymouth and that enables britain to maintain control not just the channel but if the western approach is into the channel and the great fret you know the french lack deep sea ports along their along their channel coast and basically their naval base breast is around the kind of the headland of of Brittany. So that's a problem for the French. Portsmouth and Plymouth are excellent harbours for them. But what then happens over the course of the 1780s and into the 1790s with the start of the Revolutionary Wars is a further streamlining of their strategic vision. There are really two key figures before Nelson, and nelson is a disciple of both of them his kind
学徒生涯正是在他们手下度过的。第一位是被称为胡德勋爵（Lord Hood）的人。胡德的理解是，仅仅控制通往海峡的西方航道是不够的，海军的地缘政治背景要比这更广泛。因此，他担任了驻地在地中海的舰队司令，夺取了土伦的控制权——土伦是法国南部巨大的海军基地。尽管他后来被拿破仑赶了出来——那是拿破仑最初凭借“葡萄弹清剿”成名的地方——但这对于法国人来说绝对是毁灭性的，因为当胡德在那里时，他摧毁了法国补给商们为了建造船只而储存在那里的所有海军物资。甚至可以说，特拉法加战役
of apprenticeship is served under both of them the first one is a guy called lord hood hood's understanding is that the navy it's not enough just to control the western approaches into the channel the geopolitical context is broader than that and so he serves as commander of a fleet that's based in the mediterranean he seizes control of toulon the great naval base on the on the south of France. And although he gets thrown out of it by Napoleon, it's where the whiff grapeshot, it's where Napoleon first makes his name. It's absolutely devastating for the French because while Hood is there, he destroys all the naval supplies that have been stored up there by French provisioners ready to build ships. And there's a case for saying perhaps that Trafalgar is one
或许在胡德摧毁这一切的土伦就已经赢下了。胡德明白，要成为一支有效的作战力量，皇家海军必须存在于更广阔的地缘政治背景中。因此，海军上将必须是一位外交官，必须具备这样一种意识：它不仅仅作为海军力量运作，更是在作为地缘政治力量运作。纳尔逊完全吸收了这一点。另一位对纳尔逊有极大影响的人是约翰·杰维斯（John Jervis），他在西班牙海岸外的圣文森特角打赢了一场伟大的海战——就像特拉法加战役一样，那是在1797年，当时纳尔逊登上一艘船——他当时是一名舰长。嗯，纳尔逊是第一个率领前15、60名左右的人冲锋的人，那是绝对改变了他的一刻——我们还没怎么聊过纳尔逊——将他变成了
at Toulon when Hood destroys all this stuff. And Hood understands that to be an effective fighting force, the Royal Navy has to exist in the broader geopolitical context. So an admiral has to be a diplomat, has to have this kind of sense that it's not just operating as a naval force, it's operating as a geopolitical force. And Nelson absolutely absorbs that. The other guy who's again a big big influence on nelson is a man called john jervis who wins a great battle at cape st vincent off spain just like trafalgar is in 1797 where nelson boards a ship uh he's a captain well nelson was the first person to have led the first 15 60 or something yeah to have led his men on and that was one of the moments that absolutely turned him we haven't really talked about nelson but turned him into a
民族英雄。是的。而杰维斯后来成为圣文森特伯爵（以他的伟大胜利命名），他真正关注的是两件事：他是那个真正热衷于纪律的人；他是那个致力于消除18世纪腐败残余、让海军纪律严明、精简高效的人。但他也注重给予他的舰长们自主权。这至关重要，不是吗？所以杰维斯对他的舰长们所做的是，他说：“这是计划，这就是我们要做的。但我相信，当我们进入战斗时，你们会知道我希望你们去做什么。”而这正是纳尔逊所做的。我昨天读到一篇文章，关于
national hero yes uh and jervis who later becomes earl saint vincent named after his great victory he's about two things really he's about he's the guy who's really into discipline he's the guy who's who's interested in getting rid of all the kind of the remnants of 18th century corruption, making the Navy discipline streamlined, focused. But he's also about giving his captains a sense of autonomy. That's crucial, isn't it? So what Jervis does is he says to his captains, this is the plan, this is what we're going to do. But I trust you when we get into the battle to know what I would want you to do. And that's what Nelson does. I was reading an article yesterday about the difference
乌克兰军队和俄罗斯军队的区别。作者说，俄罗斯指挥官——你知道的，一切都是自上而下的，他们没有主动性，而乌克兰人拥有北约风格的指挥系统，地面的个别指挥官
between the Ukrainian and Russian armies. And the author said, the Russian commanders, you know, it's all very top down. They have no initiative, whereas the Ukrainians have a NATO style command system where individual kind of commanders
被告知总体目标，但他们可以利用自己的主动性去尝试实现它。我想，这正是19世纪之交皇家海军的立场，也是纳尔逊和他的舰长们的立场。还有一件事，实际上我很惊讶你没有提到，因为你会喜欢它。我知道你会很乐意谈论它。
on the ground, are told the general objective, but they can use their initiative to try and achieve it. And I thought, that's exactly the Royal Navy's position, Nelson's position with his captains at the turn of the 19th century. There's one other thing, actually, which I'm surprised you haven't mentioned, because you would love it. I know you will enjoy talking about it.
这就是进攻精神。所以英国人——在我看来，皇家海军拥有这种精神，一种比法国、尤其是西班牙海军更具攻击性的精神，因为他们的海军存在是为了保护他们的殖民贸易，特别是西班牙。我的意思是，这就是他们拥有海军的原因，为了保护巨大的宝藏船队等等。而皇家海军一直培养着这种冲劲、活力和进取精神。
So it's about the ethos of aggression. So the British, it seems to me that the Royal Navy has this ethos, a much more aggressive ethos than the French, in particular the Spanish Navy, because their navies exist to protect their colonial trade, particularly Spain. I mean, that's why they have a navy, to protect the great treasure fleets and so on. And the Royal Navy has always cultivated this sort of dash and vigour and aggressiveness.
嗯，并不总是这样。正如我所说，典型的例子就是宾上将（Admiral Bing）。因为宾上将在1756年基本上放弃了梅诺卡岛（Menorca），其原因并不是非常不光彩——他认为回吉布罗陀等地更好。结果他闻名遐迩地被送上军事法庭并被处决了。汤姆，我知道你喜欢伏尔泰，对吧？你是个伏尔泰大粉丝。
Well, it hasn't always. Well, as I say, the classic example is Admiral Bing. Because Admiral Bing, in 1756, he had basically abandoned Menorca for not terribly inglorious reasons. He thought it was better to go back to Gibraltar and stuff. And he had famously been court-martialed and executed. Tom, I know you like Voltaire, don't you? You're a big Voltaire fan.
伏尔泰的大粉丝，是的。你想不想告诉大家伏尔泰说了什么？你当然想。是的，他在《老实人》（Candide）中说，英国人处决海军上将是为了鼓励其他人（pour encourager les autres）。这是一种随意的俏皮话，但事实真的如此吗？因此，南·罗杰在他的伟大历史著作中基本上指出，每一位英国船长出海时，都深知如果他们不进攻，如果他们不具攻击性，如果他们不采取
Big Voltaire fan, yeah. And do you want to tell everybody what Voltaire said? Of course you do. Yeah, he says in Condide that the English execute admirals to encourage the others, pour encourager les autres. And this is a kind of throwaway quip, but is that actually true? So NAM Rogers, in his great history, basically says that every British captain goes to see an admiral knowing that if they don't attack, if they're not aggressive, if they don't adopt a
戏剧性交战的政策，他们就面临着在自己船的甲板上被处决的风险。这在皇家海军中激发出了一种令人难以置信的攻击性，使得他们的对手越来越感到畏惧。其结果是，法国和西班牙的船长们看着皇家海军，心想如果我们与他们作战，我们可能会被打败——这是一种隐性的失败主义，是几十年乃至几百年积累的结果，但经由胡德和杰维斯的推崇而大大强化了；因为在战术层面上，作为一个舰长，一旦你发现敌人，看到进攻的机会，你就必须冲上去，否则你就会被处决。我的意思是，这显然
policy of kind of dramatic engagement, they face the risk of being executed on the deck of their own ship. And this encourages a kind of incredible aggression in the Royal Navy that their opponents find increasingly intimidating. And the result is that French and, say, Spanish captains look at the Royal Navy and think if we fight them we're probably going to be defeated it's a kind of implicit defeatism that is the result of decades and decades and decades but gets very much sharpened by both Hood and Jervis because on the tactical level the fact that you have your enemy you're a captain you see an opportunity to attack them you have to go in or else you're going to get executed. I mean, that obviously
让英国船长的头脑更加清醒。但在更广阔的意义上，面对拥有整个战区的高级将领，到18世纪90年代的胡德和杰维斯时期，发生的事情是他们认识到英国卷入了这场全面战争。所以我们在节目开始时谈到，英国花了一些时间才弄清楚他们身处全面战争之中。正是胡德和杰维斯理解了这一点，他们认识到，如果英国要取胜，仅仅进行防守是不够的。他们必须发起进攻。他们必须削弱甚至希望摧毁法国海军。他们必须攻击法国的贸易航线。他们必须竭尽所能去扼杀和窒息法国经济。因此，无论在战术还是战略
sharpens the minds of British captains. But on the broader sense, admirals with entire theatres of war, what's happened by the 1790s with Hood and Jervis is that they are recognising that Britain is involved in this total war. So we began the episode by talking about how it takes the British time to work out that they're in a total war. It's Hood and Jervis who understand that, who recognise that if Britain is going to win, it's not enough just to play a defensive game. They have to go on the attack as well. They have to cripple or hopefully destroy the French Navy. They've got to attack French trade links. They've got to try and do everything that they can to strangle and throttle the French economy. So both on the tactical and strategic
层面上，纳尔逊时代的皇家海军都极具攻击性。而纳尔逊正是这种精神的绝对化身。他是胡德和杰维斯的门徒，他的一生堪称这种暴力攻击传统和对细节绝对关注的绝对丰碑。而这些正是他将带到特拉法加战役中的品质。所以，汤姆，这是一个——我敢说——这是一场精彩演说的开端。虽然还算不上是一场完整的精彩演说，但它是一个精彩演说的开端。现在，如果你是“历史安魂曲俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的会员，你笑了。我的意思是，你就像一个皇家海军舰长，正乘风破浪驶向与西班牙人的战场。你嘴角带着微笑，心中充满欢笑和对死亡的无畏，因为你知道你可以立刻收听
level, the Royal Navy by the age of Nelson is very, very aggressive. And Nelson is the absolute embodiment of that. He is the disciple of both Hood and Jervis, and his career stands as an absolute monument to these traditions of violent aggression and of absolute attention to detail. And those are the qualities that he will bring to the Trafalgar campaign. So Tom, that is a, dare I say, it's the beginning of a tour de force. It's not a tour de force completely, but it's the beginning of a tour de force. Now, if you were a member of the Restless History Club, you're laughing. I mean, you're like a Royal Navy captain sailing into battle against the Spanish. There is a smile on your lips and laughter and death in your heart because you know that you can listen to
本系列的其余内容。如果你还不是“历史安魂曲俱乐部”的会员，那么坦白说，你甚至连个见习水手都不是。你算什么，汤姆？我的意思是，你基本上只是凑数的小金库资金——所以快加入“历史安魂曲俱乐部”吧。你知道的，英国在18世纪是一个商业大国，我们庆祝这一点非常重要。汤姆，大家应该加入“历史安魂曲俱乐部”，他们将能够收听所有这些内容。汤姆·霍兰将连续几个小时谈论海军战术和火炮。我看过他的笔记，他已经准备好大谈特谈了。他要讲的甚至不是按分钟计，而是几乎按秒计，充满了各种刺激。如果我们足够幸运，他甚至可能会给你唱上一段，谁知道呢？所以
the rest of this series right away. If you're not a member of the Restless History Club, then frankly, you're not even a midshipman. What what are you tom i mean you're you're part of the slush fund basically so join the rest is history club this is you know britain was a commercial power in the 18th century it's very important that we celebrate that tom people should join the rest is history club they'll be able to listen to all of this tom holland will be speaking for hours and hours about naval tactics and gunnery i've seen his notes he's got he's ready to go he's going to do it it's not even minute by minute it's practically second by second all sorts of excitement if we're very lucky he might do you might sing who knows so join the
赶快加入“历史安魂曲俱乐部”吧。伴随着这个重磅消息，再见。拜拜。
rest is history club forthwith and on that bombshell goodbye bye Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史安魂曲》。如需收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。